[Music]
I met marshmallow that was kind of cool
oh yeah how's the boy
he's good you met him before man we've
corresponded a handful I walked in the
suite and he was like bro oh [__] he's
like I still watch you every morning I
was like no way really he's like yeah I
was like holy [__] that's that's sick
he's like yeah man
all right and then he like left and went
over
and like started talking to somebody
else and I was like ah damn
yeah he uh I remember he messed he
messaged me one morning yeah this is
just corroborating he's a good dude he
uh
he messaged me like quoting some video I
had posted and I was like oh you watched
that he's like yeah dude every morning I
was like whoa
that's that's love so he's watching both
of us every single morning that's what
he said man he's just every morning
clocks in it's part of his the routine
it's the routine man yeah shower make
some oats meditate marshmallows watching
us with his [__] nuts out
[Music]
might be dude or he's getting ready
yeah fresh out there polishing the
helmet yeah
I'm surprised it's still him under that
[__] thing I'm like
dude just Outsource this [__]
you know
you could be playing nine shows at once
right now you could be even [__]
Cambodia playing a show
and here you're the worst person to be
giving advice dude you would Outsource
your your entire social life if you
could
oh
my God I'd be hiring people to go out
and do [__] let cloning become available
watch how fast Cody goes straight to it
yeah
oh yeah because it's like I need okay I
need a social me
uh I need a me that the charity
uh I need a me that eats eating
no actually that'll be me yeah yeah that
one will be me for sure yeah yeah all
social interactions and uh DJ
yeah need one for training
the DJ one just stays in the clouds and
it just waits for the yearly excess set
yeah exactly you fire them up yeah here
you go bro your time to shine go for it
get out there yeah
do your [__] thing yeah and then and
then he he you know Alesso the DJ
you want me to help you pick that up
what
that name that's kind of big you want
you want me to help you pick that up
what do you mean Alesso it's kind of a
big name yeah oh yeah nice okay how did
I miss that again Jesus [__] Christ
yeah sorry would you mind uh hold on I
gotta yeah hold on dude I got you hold
on it's pretty heavy so you know Alesso
right oh sorry on three yeah one two
three alysso ah
there you go uh yeah
um so you're aware of Alesso yeah
boom boom
I met him he came over and he's like oh
by the way this is the last time
oh
it's kind of crazy
what did he turn you and he was like
how's it going Cody do you have any
stupendous win this weekend
I'm like stupendous I don't know but I
did have a couple uh fantastic wins ah
fantastic
you had a marvelous win Maybe
you know it's like a French looking guy
came over and started like ask
marshmallow question Marshall's like oh
by the way this is Alesso and I was like
hi
and then they and then security removed
me from The Suite they're like yo this
is the guy pulling too much dude acid
loops and hops getting mad wait weren't
you on hoops and hops we've been looking
for your ass
yeah this is the [__] chillest guy in
the room we gotta get him out of here
man yeah this guy has too many friends
everyone downstairs in the casino is
asking about him that's Sports Cody
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah my clones yeah
Fitness Cody bro I I mean I would
I'm talking [__] but if I could have
stand-up Noel and I just sent him out
and I get the game all day that's what
I'm saying so you should do you should
start doing stand-up in a helmet
[__] racing helmet
yeah just wear anything like a ah helmet
no bro that's been my big meta this
whole time I lied about all this [__]
racing interest just so I could stand up
in a helmet yes exactly and have an AI
synthesizer do your voice
and then it's just a dude all right
let's just play play a set and have a
guy just like motion like he's saying it
yeah he's just in there yeah
and then I mean AI will be so Advanced
if someone heckles me I can just
pre-record
roasts and anti-hackles I'm with it I'm
sitting here chatting [__] but you know
what
let's get the Clones
let's get them in here dude I can't wait
we need them we do need them
if you have clones would you just hang
out with yourself because you know you
best
yeah just it's a matter of
how far you would go
with yourself you know yeah
you know would you ever like
oh no watching porn with the boys boys
I meant I mean yeah I guess that's less
weird than what I'm about to say what
gang banging yourself
between yourself in a room
oh and you just beat off in front of
yourself that was like making out you
know
laughs
would you hook up with yourself
[Laughter]
I think valid [__] question I think
you would
why
because I think you would I don't really
I don't really
you know when I there there have there
have been times when I've been really in
shape where I've looked in the mirror
and been like I like the way I look but
that's like that was like one time in my
life I got that turned on by myself see
here's the thing would it feel like
you're jacking off no right
it would feel like you're jacking off
another dude yeah
yeah
hmm
this is something you're gonna have to
figure out when you get your clone tough
one you have to figure this out and you
get your clone dude
is it cheating
oh
I don't know man
maybe not technically you're just
jacking off
maybe not
so you wouldn't do it nah
you just you just post up
I'm like no dude I'm Gonna Keep My
clones in a shed I don't want them
thinking that oh okay you know oh yeah
yeah true a clones need to understand
that they're still beneath me yeah keep
them in check I'm their creator you know
they're not that's cruel isn't it no
it's kind of like yeah I mean it's
they're not my equal
it's inhumane they are humans they have
the same thoughts it's like keeping
someone locked in your basement you
wouldn't do that hey man
I made these [__] okay they
came from me if it wasn't for me they
wouldn't be nothing and they have to
remember that so you keep your kids
in a shed too
well they're they're a little bit
different because they're half me yeah
okay so it's half Alina so I'm gonna I'm
gonna love them I want to take care of
them I want them to be fine but like
something that's just straight me like
I'm gonna let it know you're not
by this you know gift of God this
doesn't Grant you the right to go out in
public and be me to an unlimited degree
I'm telling you what degree you can be
me okay right you know
but you could very well be a clone right
now
so imagine someone locking you up and
you having that thought we're like no
I'm the original one they'd have that
same thought they'd be like I'm the
original
now I'm just gonna write why is my clone
allowed to be the main guy or I saw a
film where some clones lock up their
master
they don't know Master is right best
word
that's the master okay if I make him
work
I own them you know right yeah yeah that
is a weird ass thing if you pay for a
clone do you own it
ah Jesus Christ
that's tough that's really tough
it's a good moral question dude yeah it
really is this is a good it's a really
good thought exercise I'm glad we're
doing this so would you jack one of them
off or not